this is cereth westerner sorry and calm
and in this video I'm going to
demonstrate how to remove surgical
sutures specifically simple interrupted
sutures sutures which are also called
stitches are used to close a wound that
could have been sustained through like
an injury or a surgical procedure now
there's various types of surgical
patterns and in this video I'm going to
demonstrate how to remove the most
common type of surgical pattern which is
the simple interrupted suture and this
is where their individual sutures used
to close the wound in addition as a
nurse you can see various types and here
you will see pictured a simple
continuous suture which is just as the
name says a continuous strand of suture
closing the wound in addition to a
vertical mattress suture a horizontal
mattress suture a continuous blanket
suture also called a forward
interlocking suture and finally an
interrupted cruciate suture as well and
cruciate just means cross-shaped now
keep in mind not all sutures need to be
removed some suture material is made out
of a dissolvable substance where I'll
actually dissolve in the body itself
while others have to be manually removed
which is what we're going to be doing in
this video
in addition depending on where the
suture is located and the depth the
wound that the suture is closing the
suture can stay in for as little as five
days versus two weeks first what you
want to do is you want to verify the
physician's order because as a nurse
before you can remove sutures you have
to have an order next what you want to
do is explain the procedure to the
patient and get their verbal consent a
lot of patients ask is this going to be
painful no usually it's not a lot of
patients report a tugging or pulling
sensation but you can always give the
patient pain medication if ordered prior
to the removal of the sutures then
gather your supplies one thing you'll
need is a dressing change tray and
before you actually remove your sutures
you'll always want to follow your
Hospital protocols because some
hospitals say use sterile gloves to
remove the sutures while others say you
can just use clean gloves in this video
we're going to demonstrate using sterile
gloves
so our sterile gloves will come
here along with our sterile drape to put
our supplies on and some gauze and our
antiseptic to actually clean the suture
line before and after the removal then
of course you're going to need a suture
removal kit and this comes with our
tweezers our scissors to remove to cut
the suture and some gauze to help us
keep them in place and then you'll need
some steri-strips and the steri-strips
will be placed on the site where the
individual suture was removed because
one complication of suture removal is
wound dehiscence and this is where your
womb will open up prematurely and
putting these on will help prevent that
then you're going to perform hand
hygiene and dawn clean gloves because
first of all we want to do is we want to
assess our womb before we remove the
sutures so you're going to remove any
old dressings that are present and first
what you want to do is you want to check
for infection is the site really red is
it warm to the touch
are there any hard areas is it using
foul looking drainage or has a smell
next you want to look at the suture line
itself does the skin look nice and fused
together or does it look weak like if
you remove one of these sutures that
wound is going to pop open and if any of
that is present you want to notify the
physician before actually removing the
sutures then we're going to doll for
gloves perform hand hygiene and a
prepper supplies first what we're going
to do is we're going to open up our
dressing change tray and whenever you
open these up on the top is usually the
sterile drape which we're going to
easily just grab and lay over here and
the sterile gloves which we're going to
lay right here and what we're going to
be doing is opening up this sterile
drape and we're going to drop our suture
removal kit supplies and our
steri-strips onto the sterile drape
because we're trying to keep everything
as sterile as possible to help prevent
infection so what we're going to do now
is open up our drapes so we're just
going to gently open it and we have
about two inches on the inside to be
able to reach so we can open it up
now let's open our supplies and drop it
on to our field so first what we're
gonna do is open our suture removal drop
that in there and then discard that and
then take our steri-strips and do the
same now we're going to dawn our sterile
gloves and if you don't know how to put
on sterile gloves please watch my video
on that so what we're gonna do is pull
these tabs open lay these down and I'm
gonna glove my right hand first cuz I'm
right-handed so I'm going to grab this
cuff and pull it over my hand and pull
the cuff down then I'm going to take
this hand which is sterile and slide it
underneath the cuff part of this and I
want to be careful not to touch my other
hand okay now what we're gonna do is
open up or antiseptic because we're
going to use this to clean the wound
before suture removal and after this
helps decrease infection so let's open
these up and inside you will have three
swabs that have antiseptic on them so
now take the antiseptic swab and clean
along the wound this is going to prevent
infection and then what we're gonna do
is discard the swab and let the area dry
now that the area is dried we are ready
to remove the sutures so we're going to
take our galls and we're just going to
set it beside of our work area because
this is where we're going to be dropping
each suture and we want to dispose of
those properly according to your
hospital protocol because it's a
biohazard and you want to count how many
sutures you're removed and analyze them
make sure the whole suture thread is
intact and document so we're going to
take our tweezers and put those in our
non-dominant hand and we're going to
take our scissors and put those in our
dominant hand and what we're going to do
first is we're going to remove every
other suture starting at the second
suture why is that because we want to
prevent this wound from opening up
prematurely so doing that will help
hopefully prevent that
and then after we remove every other
suture before we remove the other
sutures we're going to put steri-strips
just to help reinforce that wound even
more so two things you want to remember
prior to removing sutures this is a
really big thing you got to keep in mind
where you actually cut the suture thread
we're not going to cut on this side of
the knot why is that if we cut that side
of the knot when we go to pull that knot
out this part of the thread that's been
in contact with the outside environment
has germs on it it's going to slide
underneath that wound introducing all
those germs into that wound leading to
possible infection so we want to cut on
this side of the knot that's closest to
the skin so always remember that with
these simple interrupted sutures in
addition when we're actually removing
the thread when we grab the knot we
don't want to grab the knot and pull the
suture thread away from the wound why is
that if we pull away that's going to
create tension on this incision line
possibly leading to opening up so when
we actually pull the thread up we're
going to lift up gently and then we're
going to pull over the wound starting at
our second suture what we're going to do
is we're going to grasp the not with our
tweezers then we're going to take this
scissors and we're going to just cut
that part of the thread then we're going
to lift up and pull over the wound and
then just look at your suture make sure
it's intact it hasn't fell apart or
anything like that then drop it into
your gauze then we're gonna do the same
thing with the other suture so grab the
knot snip underneath it then lift up and
then pull over the wound and then just
check your suture thread and drop in the
ghost then take a new antiseptic swab
and clean the areas where you remove the
suture and let that dry then we're going
to apply our steri-strips in the area
where we removed each suture and you'll
want to cut your steri-strips where
they're at least 3/4 of an angel'
each side of the incision and space them
about 1/8 inch apart so we're going to
just take our steri-strip and line it up
where we have about 3/4 of an inch on
each side and whenever you're applying
steri-strips you want to gently lay down
one part of it smooth it down and then
gently lay down the other side don't
pull it or tug on it to create tension
because series strips are strong and
they can actually tear the skin then
we're gonna do the same thing with our
other part line it up smooth it down and
then gently lay on the other side now
we're going to remove the remaining
suture so again just grab your knot cut
underneath pull up and then pull over
and analyze your thread looks good and
then placing the gauze again repeat the
same process for the next suture grasp
the knot cut underneath and lift up and
pull over look at it looks good and drop
it in the gauze and then our last one
same thing grab the knot underneath lift
up a little bit and then pull over look
at your suture looks good now let's say
while we were removing it this was
starting to open up prematurely we would
stop what we were doing don't remove any
more sutures cover it up with a sterile
gauze and notified the physician
immediately then we're going to take a
new antiseptic swab and we're just going
to clean those areas again where we
remove the sutures and we're gonna let
that dry the side is dry so now we're
going to apply our steri-strips the same
way we did before leaving 3/4 inch on
each side of the incision about 1/8 inch
apart higher next one
and then apply our last one same way
after doing that you'll want to look at
the site and ask yourself is this an
area that's going to easily have
friction on it like rubbing up against
jeans or experience a lot of moisture if
so you'll want to apply a dressing give
the patient dressing supplies to change
it regularly educate them about signs
and symptoms of infection and winds who
expect these steri-strips to fall off
which is usually within ten days and
tell them to let them follow all by
themselves and do not remove them then
after that what you want to do is you
want to
Dolf your gloves perform hand hygiene
and document okay so that is how you
remove surgical sutures thank you so
much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos